the kids who watch the original Masters
of the Universe cartoons are well into
adulthood now and some might notice that
the show isn't quite what they remember
from back in the day here are some of
the bizarre hilarious and worrying
things that only adults will notice in
Hemans Adventures being so distracted by
all the thrilling action and scary
monsters most kids didn't care about the
ideology that fueled he-man and the
Masters of the Universe capitalism but
present-day parents who are all too used
to their kids begging for toys they've
seen on TV now recognized that one of
the main purposes of the he-man cartoon
was to move merchandise the show kicked
off an action figure craze in the 80s
selling hundreds of millions of dollars
worth of toys and every episode of
he-man and the Masters of the Universe
served as its own 30-minute ad many
episodes would introduce some
never-before-seen character who just so
happened to be now available in
action-figure format toy stores these
characters all seem to possess a unique
ability or feature that conveniently
enough really popped when molded in
plastic take mechanic or buzz off for
example two characters who can only
possibly have been conceived so as to
make up a shortfall in the merch budget
there's no other explanation he-man and
the Masters of the Universe was
obviously heavily inspired by other
shows and movies after all a
muscle-bound guy and a loincloth
fighting monsters in a strange world
that's some straight-up Conan the
Barbarian stuff right there and that's
fine Conan itself borrowed plenty of
sci-fi and fantasy tropes and he-man
does the same
that's just how media works it's just
that adults will notice Hemans cribbing
is especially lazy he-man itself is an
old phrase that means manly man while
other hastily named characters include a
skeleton named Skeletor and a sorceress
named the sorceress but at least those
are mostly innocuous examples some of
the other he-man characters have names
that well let's just say they take on a
different dimension once you're all
grown up
isn't that right fist oh and when Fisto
offers you his hand
that's a big offer there might not be
too many people on Eternia but there are
clearly plenty of gems since every
single character on he-man and the
Masters of the Universe is in fantastic
shape all of the male characters are as
ripped as professional bodybuilders with
enormous muscles covering each of them
from head to toe
the women meanwhile fit right into the
hugely unrealistic 80s standard of
beauty with the battle of good versus
evil that constantly plagues Eternia
it's hard to imagine how the men have
four hours a day to lift weights or how
the women fit in the Pilates yoga and
aerobics they must be doing on the
regular regardless the men and women of
he-man and the Masters of the Universe
like to show off all that hard work and
pretty much everyone wears incredibly
revealing clothing except orko of course
but that would be kind of weird
according to Masters of the Universe
lore he-man is the most powerful
individual in existence and he's got
plenty of powers and tools that have
helped him reach that status the power
of Grayskull for one as well as brute
physical strength and the Power Sword a
much coveted Excalibur like relic
despite those gifts however he-man is
actually surprisingly wishy-washy most
likely because the show's non serialized
nature means things always have to get
back to normal by the end of each
episode as a result he-man never really
uses much of the power afforded to him
he always lets bad guys get away
including Skeletor who's pretty much the
king of the bad guys since he knows
he'll be back to fight Skeletor another
day he-man always allows him to flee
back to his headquarters from which he
can continue his campaign of terror the
show's hero could easily make life
better for the people of Eternia by
ending his war and killing Skeletor with
the power sword the first chance he gets
then there'd be no more show would there
having dominion over a whole planet or
even the universe is no easy feat and
not even an evil all-powerful sorcerer
can do it alone Skeletor boasts a huge
crew of powerful servants all loyal II
devoted to helping their boss destroy
he-man and take over Eternia
but Skeletor is so evil that he doesn't
even appreciate how baddies like beast
man and evil-lyn lay everything on the
line for him day after day risking life
limb and more in service to this angry
cackling skeleton he's forever unhappy
with the performance of his underlings
mainly because they never managed to
defeat he-man or complete the task he
sent them to do and he always happens to
let them know it with a threat of
violence or the withering put-down
even though robots are smarter than you
Skeletor best be careful best-case
scenario is put-upon employees please to
he-man sighed and reveals all kinds of
secrets to return as hero worst case
scenario they unionized and then
Skeletor is really in trouble
even today animation is a
labor-intensive and expensive crafts and
things were even tougher back in the
early 80s when he man in the Masters of
the Universe air production company
Filmation churned out 65 episodes per
season and the crew had to find some
shortcuts to keep things running
smoothly kids with no frame of reference
wouldn't notice but adults with a
cynical eye will easily spot the show's
cost-cutting measures the same handful
of music cues are used over and over and
so are a number of animation sequences
how many times do we see he man and
battle cat running or walking the basic
animation of their steps repeated for a
good chunk of screen time and of course
at least once per episode Prince Adam is
going to step in front of Castle
Grayskull and gradually transform into
he-man it's a good lesson for kids
always recycle check out one of our
newest videos right here Plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuffs
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]